Hello and welcome. Today's video is
going to be pretty chill because today
we're just going to look at my stuff
because I actually dedicated an entire
room for terraforming miles. Believe it
or not, we got these three pictures.
They are of course representing the
earth tax, the moon tax, and the jovian
tax. The map itself I got printed in
some sort of aluminum mix. So, it's one
big piece. It doesn't fold. So, it's
actually literally impossible to bring
to my friends because it's it it doesn't
fit in my car. The board is actually so
wide that it's even hard to pass cards
to each other when you're drafting and
stuff. So to counter this problem, we
actually invented this genius device
that actually enables us to reach
everywhere on the map without having to
get up from our seat.
Yep.
So
nice attack.
And we have some of the expansions. The
Pathfinder expansion is my favorite one.
This board is already incorporated into
the big board, but if you don't have the
big board, you're going to use this. Oh,
and this one I like a lot. This is
basically a dispenser for hand
sanitizer. I kind of lost the hand
sanitizer part of it, but you know, if
you find the hand sanitizer and put it
up there, it absolutely works. Then we
got some of the user made colonies here.
Japetus Leage Station Investor. These
are our favorites. I also kind of like
Mercury and Titania, but they feel a
little bit invalid. Then we have a tag
tracker. It looks nice, but my
experience is that you usually only use
it to like keep track of a few attacks
or something if you're running an earth
tech strategy or something. These are
weighted iron money. I really like
those. It feels so nice in your hand
that there's a little bit weight to the
money instead of these cheap things you
get with the game. And these are some
upgrades for like animals and signs and
stuff. These are kind of nice, but I
actually like these more because they
have the 1 5 10 numbers and they might
not be as cute as the other one, but
they are much better. And speaking of
upgrades you can't live without, I
introduce you to the Meister.
It's basically like a big astronaut with
like an astronaut and a helmet. The only
function of the Meister is basically
that you can choose your player color.
Some would say that the Meister is just
really there, but he doesn't really do
anything. But I want to defend the
Meister here. I think he is actually
worth having around still. It's kind of
like your grandparents, right?
Technically, they don't really
contribute in any meaningful way, but
you know, you keep them around because
you love them. That's how I feel about
the Meister. Then we got the two card
towers here that came with the
Terraforming Mask big box. These are
really nice because if you don't have
them and you have all your cards
sleeved, they're just going to fall all
over the place. So, the card towers are
actually really cool. I like them. Then
we got some preludes and some
corporations here. We used to have more
corporations, but we kind of sorted out
the ones that weren't fun or good
enough. Simply just had too much text
because we can't be bothered to read all
of that. Then we got the water towers
over here. And like you probably guessed
by now, I actually have like double of
everything. I actually got the big box
twice, which sounds pretty dumb, but
when you're playing on the big map here,
you kind of need two of everything. You
need double the cubes. You need double
the 3D tiles and stuff. And I can
actually tell them apart because I have
a little or sticker on the right one
right there. The master over here is
like the turn marker. I got it painted.
I didn't paint it myself. One of my
friends painted it because I suck at
painting. But that turned out really
great. Then we got some high orbit
expansion here. We don't play with that
every time, but sometimes we do, and it
kind of adds something to the game. I
have a little bit of issues with this
expansion, but at the same time, they're
also kind of fun. Then we got some of
these IKEA rolling kitchen table
thingies because it's so nice to have
extra space for storage, extra space for
like all of these weird 3D tiles and
stuff. And then we even put a third
table over here for even more storage
space. And I know this is a big table,
right? But Mega Mask is just so huge. So
you you need all the space you can get,
basically. Then we got some of the extra
maps. And this picture here, if you're
curious, that's basically me being
bored. So basically I just designed how
I wanted my dream gaming hub to look
like. Not important. The picture over
here is something we put together
ourselves. So of course luxury food had
to be the bubble tea and anti-gravity
technology is the spaceman farting which
makes no sense. I even got some LED
lights that looks like the different
planets but they were kind of
underwhelming. This is like the only
thing I regret buying. These were not
worth it. Of course you also need some
additional trading fleets. There are
actually some even cooler trading fleets
on Etsy where they had a little docking
station but I already had these ones. So
obviously no one else gets to play with
the Millennium Falcon. That one is mine.
Then we also got the USS Enterprise and
this one is like a Cllingon ship or
something. That's what one of my nerd
friends has been telling me. I will say
that all the user made stuff including
the map is like 3 years old now. So
there are definitely newer versions of
the map that includes some of the newer
fan mail expansions. So if you want to
get some of the stuff yourself, I
recommend checking out the Facebook
group or the Discord group. On Facebook,
you can definitely find some people who
want to sell their user made stuff or at
least they can point you in the
direction of how to get it. So, for
example, shout out to this guy, Robert
Solo, who's been pasting in the
Terraform Mass Facebook group 25,93
times. No, sorry. He just made he he
just made nine more 25,912
times. All right, that pretty much
concludes the part that's about
Terraforming M. But I also have some
other games I want to show you. So,
check out part two.
What's up, Dan? Nois.